&gt;&gt; Before we start this unit, let's take another look at MathQuill. In the last
section, we were able to type in inequalities and interval notations for our
answers. Now, we're going to try some fractions. In a fraction in MathQuill is
very similar to what you've done in the past. You simply going to type in the
numerator then the forward slash and then the denominator. Mathquill will do all
the hard work for you and will make your fraction look nice. But sometimes we
don't want just a fraction, sometimes you want a little bit more. After typing
in a fraction, you'll notice that your cursor bar is in the denominator. To move
the cursor bar from the denominator, simply hit the over arrow key and it will
shift back up to the main line. And now you're ready to continue typing just
like before. You would type x plus sign and then 1. And it turns out anytime
you're typing inside a MathQuill box, you can just use your arrow keys as
navigation. Try playing around with MathQuill and use these arrow keys. Don't
worry about making a mistake because you can always hit Delete. When you play
around with it, you'll notice that the cursor bar will move up and down inside
of a fraction. You can even hit the carrot symbol and then you can create an
exponent cursor. We won't cover this now, but if you want to play around with
it, feel free to. We'll do this again later.